this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsay show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host ken
coleman ramsey personality number one
best-selling author is my co-host today
as we answer your questions about your
life your money and with ken being here
particularly your career that's right
you're thinking about a new job you're
thinking about participating in the
great resignation as they're calling it
out there uh you're thinking about
shifting and moving to something with
purpose uh ken's new best seller
paycheck to purpose answers that and
he's here to answer your questions he
does that several hours a day on radio
as well but joins us here for the three
hours of the ramsey show today open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five mike starts us off
this hour in charlotte hey mike how are
you
good i'm uh work
gonna be on my last uh baggy step two
debt which is a auto loan that has zero
percent interest
and i'm wondering why i should not well
thank you i'm wondering
why i should not just go ahead and start
saving for baby step three and just pay
that loan out per its terms for the next
10 months
considering mathematically it makes no
difference
well mathematically does make a
difference because we're not talking
just about interest rate we're talking
about cash flow
and also we're talking about you
completely changing your view and your
habits on debt
because the shortest distance between
where you are and wealth is to do away
with and stay away from
debt
and the way you frame the question makes
it sound like you think this is still
smart
like you do it again
no no i would not okay if you wouldn't
do it again then let's get rid of it
okay
fair enough it's it's a mindset shift as
much as it is a math equation personal
finance is 80 behavior it's only 20 head
knowledge and so your cash flow is being
eaten up by a freaking car payment and
so what you're doing is you're
permanently drawing a line in the sand
and saying that's it i don't borrow
money anymore
particularly for stupid cars
and
you know and when you break that cycle
in your head that's when you begin to
move forward on things
it's not just what is the interest rate
uh if interest you know if people were
doing math all the time they wouldn't be
using credit cards if they're doing math
they wouldn't have gotten a student loan
well i think it is a math issue and i
think you've just seen it the wrong way
the reality is whatever that car payment
is let's say it's 350 for and i think
the average car payment's in that range
400 500. it's now 500. my goodness it's
gone up several years ago i did a video
for our company it was like 450. yeah so
you take that number out of that monthly
budget right is you're not paying all of
a sudden
it is the math problem in the right way
now all of a sudden we've got some
freedom to put that money as rachel says
freedom to spend it gets that emergency
fund juiced and full up so much faster
and you never know what could happen to
where oh well i've got five more months
and get rid of it now part of the math
equation is cash flow cash cash cash
yeah and and your most powerful wealth
building tool is your income so
eliminate the pain don't give your
income to someone else even if it's a
zero percent yeah don't do it good good
question though fair question all right
leo is with us in houston texas hey leo
what's up
hey mr randy thanks for taking my call i
appreciate it and i also appreciate
everything you do i think you all are
great thank you sir how can we help
all right uh long story short i'm a
nurse in the healthcare field um
i've saved a little bit of money here so
i have about you know 75 000
saved in my accounts
the thing is uh i've got about 60 000
left from student loans
and you know i'm like you you know i
think about paying it off real quick i
want to put a lump down just to you know
take care of the phone as much as i can
but i know it sounds kind of
uh
sounds kind of like
kind of straightforward question but
with the new administration uh coming in
do i have to wait
until they make an announcement of like
whether or not they're gonna
relieve some of the student loans
because they started to do it with some
of the people in public service
so i was just kind of kind of wondering
what your thoughts on that because i'm
just sort of sitting here and
you know kind of trying to play the
calculation game but you know you know
just wondering what y'all's advice on
that is cool well i'm glad you picked
nursing it's a great field to go into
very well done
and sixty thousand in debt what's your
income
it's about eighty thousand good for you
how old are you
i'm a little bit older uh my i'm 40 so i
got a late start but you know that's
okay so
well but here's the thing let's go back
on a couple of elements of your question
number one the biden administration has
not done any student loan forgiveness at
all that was not already on the books
they've not initiated a single thing uh
they've been in office for 10 months 11
months
almost 12 months
and um
and so they've not done anything yet now
they've all talked a lot but welcome to
washington dc
um now and here's the second thing now
you can do whatever you want to do dude
i mean you do whatever you want to do
but what you're asking is you're asking
ken and i
so i'm 61 years old
and i've yet to receive a blessing
from washington dc
either party okay
neither neither president reagan bush
clinton
carter
these are all while i was an adult
okay obama uh who am i leaving out
second bush trump bush and bush
i've yet to get a check from any of
these people
you know you know where you know where i
built all of the wealth that we've built
is i took control of my own life and i
decided i was going to control my house
not wait on the white house
yes sir and so that's it's just a
philosophy of life i think those people
suck all of them
and i'm not waiting on any of them i
think they're all a tick on the butt of
america yeah and they're parasites and i
don't think i'm going to wait on any of
them for me to have a high quality life
yeah while you're waiting on that wait
for pigs to fly i mean it's the same
exact scenario
think about how much further along
you're going to be in your life if you
cut that check today
today yeah i mean i've got 15 left over
i have like three friends that are uh
politicians
uh at a four if you count some local
people
but uh at a national level and uh and
and uh and they're friends of mine and i
i appreciate who they are
but uh i ain't waiting on any of them
to fix my
life leo
because you're gonna have a long
wait if you wait on someone in the white
house to fix your life your life is
gonna suck
so no don't wait on biden to fix your
life don't wait on trump to get
reelected to fix your life don't wait on
whoever you want to throw in the pie
here of disgust but don't do it yeah and
let me let me take this on practically
in 30 seconds folks let me just give you
the other side of the story that's a
campaign promise you might hear it from
the other side of the aisle so dave and
i aren't picking on biting don't get
your i'm picking on all of that
but listen to this it's a campaign
promise it is not good government
business all right for them to pay these
off
they make too much money off of this
there's state dollars invested in this
this is one of the most
i mean slimy intricate situation and
they're not going to ever do it there's
too many political reasons not to do it
don't buy the lie ever they're never
going to do it
i'm just going to lay it out i mean
they've done a lot of stuff i never
thought they would do but i'm not
sitting around waiting on them to fix my
life i know that no pay it off dude fast
as you can oh by the way you borrowed it
too
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
if you're ready to get out there and
find a job you love then you need to
hear this
job hunting can be stressful and time
consuming but my friends at zip
recruiter have made the whole job search
way easier ziprecruiter is rated the
number one job site in the us by g2 and
it's free so how does it work first go
to ziprecruiter.com
ken
then create a free profile and let their
technology do the hard work by finding
and sending you jobs that are a great
fit and get this
zip recruiter pitches your profile to
companies whose jobs match your skills
and experience if someone from that
company likes your profile they can
personally invite you to apply for the
job so if you're ready for an easier job
search check out ziprecruiter sign up
for free right now at ziprecruiter.com
ken that's ziprecruiter.com
ken sign up today absolutely free and
let zip recruiter work for you
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today well the christmas
countdown is on and at ramsey solutions
we've been in a christmas frame of mind
for many weeks now and we're having a
great time handing out cash as part of
our christmas cash giveaway because if
you didn't know giving is the most fun
you'll ever have with money
every year we celebrate christmas with
our ramsey show listeners with an
awesome tradition our ramsey christmas
cash giveaway this year we're giving
away 500 every week already have several
times and a grand prize of five thousand
dollars up until christmas
uh you can enter to win every day to
increase your chances of winning no
purchase is necessary ramsey solutions
dot com
slash giveaway and we know you plan on
doing a lot of giving everything's on
sale at our website it's our biggest
cyber monday sale ever
right now you can get up to 79 percent
off a lot of our books are on at 10 each
and today we've got special deals from
all of our ramsey personalities it's the
perfect day to get christy wright's 2022
goal planner rachel cruz's money
assessment and gen coleman's career
assessment because these are the lowest
prices we've ever put them on the site
friday we broke the internet during
black friday some of you tried to get on
then
and uh so uh we've jacked up everything
right now and
it carried some of our black friday
prices over into cyber monday so you can
still get the deals so check them all
out if you missed out on friday we were
down for a few hours and uh
over here working her tail off trying to
find that uh line of corrupted code but
we got her and got her back up and uh no
problems now we're all here to help you
check out ramseysolutions.com hit the
store for all
the deals tis the season by the way you
know they called me in to help out with
that and i was able to find it that one
little piece of code dave i just want to
make sure you knew that because i forgot
to send you an email
i have no response to this level of
lying
i honestly couldn't believe i got that
far out of nowhere
you you finding a line of corrupted code
would be like me finding a line of
corruption
corrupted we wouldn't know it was
corrupted if we found it so thankful for
smart we know what a corrupted
politician is but we don't know what a
corrupted code is so but we do have
about 400 and something people in this
building that are phenomenal at uh all
things digital and uh
includes the uh swat tactical team that
went in there and found unbelievable the
internet hiccuped and um there you go
who knew yeah things we didn't have to
worry about when i started this business
isn't that the truth i read the email
and i go wow
it's amazing what we get to do because
of really smart people yeah
and how dependent we are yeah oh isn't
that the truth all right weston's with
us in nashville hey weston welcome to
the ramsey show
howdy sir thank you for taking my call
sure what's up
hey so i'm also a nurse i'm on baby step
four and what my question is is should i
i have money set aside to go to seminary
right now because i'm wanting to change
careers but should i use that money to
to go to seminary or should i use that
money to
make a down payment on a home wow
from nursing to seminary
yes sir that's a pretty that's an
interesting call i like it yes sir uh
how old are you
26 years old sir okay when will you
enter seminary if you don't buy a house
and have the money
if i don't buy a house then i i could do
it um january and you would take you how
long
to complete seminary
three years i would get my master's in
divinity sir okay all right what's the
goal what's the end
the end result
the end goal is i would love to be a
pastor and that's why like i've read um
your book proximity principle what i
want to do is i want to faithfully serve
um
serve the people of
serve god's people
and what i've been doing is obviously
reading my bible reading reading the the
books and and serving as best as i can
what i'm concerned about is that i won't
be fully educated to
serve as best as i can not really i'm
not chasing a degree i'm not chasing a
piece of paper i'm just chasing the
maximum amount of education yes sir yes
sir
well you're aware there's a lot of
highly effective pastors that do not
have an mdf yeah
yes sir okay my dad pastored started two
churches pastored for 47 years
and did not get his m-dip now he did go
to bible college and he did a lot of
studying and the guy read commentaries
still reads commentaries um so i think
that what you've got to understand is
there is opportunity for you to get more
biblical knowledge
to learn and continue to learn whether
you have an mdiv or not now i'm not
trying to talk you out of doing an mdiv
but i do think you've got to understand
that there are multiple pathways
and different levels of education none
of which it's not table stakes in that
yeah that's right
i mean the knowledge that you get from
the mdf is not table stakes
to be a pastor
uh uh and so i want you to understand
that and so then that makes me back up
and say i i want you to go i'm more
worried about seminary and more worried
about you going into the ministry than i
am you're buying a house so let's just
put take the house off the table and
let's move towards uh move towards your
new career as fast as we can and um but
i
i
might add some steps to your career
transition to see if you really
want to spend the money and the time on
an mdiv you don't have to spend three
years to get an mdf to be qualified so
let's let's play this out are you
wanting to be a senior pastor as it
stands today at 26.
is that the goal
eventually but i don't i don't think
right now i have the spiritual no no no
no no no no and you don't and it's okay
but let's let's back this up now if
right now this can change we know it's
ministry but it could be senior pastor
maybe you find as you get into it that
you'd rather be an executive pastor
that's just as much ministry as a as a
person who's preaching on sundays i
think you got to actually look to get in
uh in a volunteer ministry position
you're a nurse right now you're in great
shape financially i want to see you try
to work towards a part-time so right now
volunteer and then try to move to a
part-time ministry position churches
need folks like you who they can't pay
full-time and but they need somebody to
step in and i would i would truly work
the proximity principle which for the
audience says in order to do what you
want to do ministry pastoral work got to
be around people that are doing it in
places where it's happening get in and
sample and taste and see
all the different types of ministry
positions at 26 you can learn a lot just
from doing that dave and then you
volunteer a little bit maybe a part-time
role and you start
at a bible college that would count
towards an mdiv yeah but don't wait to
start your ministry until you finish
them diff yeah get into and see what you
know maybe it's youth maybe it's singles
maybe it's you know pastoral care where
you spend your whole week visiting
people
counseling is a form of ministry and
then of course the senior pastor or the
executive pastor really need to get in
and see it taste it experience a little
bit of it and then at 26 27 28 you get a
better idea which path you want to walk
yeah and we're throwing around inside
baseball terms mdiv stands for masters
in divinity
for those of you that are wondering what
the flip we're talking about that's
right but um yeah get a master's degree
in seminary is what it amounts to and um
it certainly qualifies you to do a lot
of things in the uh in the church world
uh without a doubt the knowledge base
does not the piece of paper and he's
approaching that from the right angle
but i to answer your overall question i
would put your career shift
ahead of
purchasing a home right now uh you've
got plenty of time to buy a home later
and um it's a weird market to buy in
anyway right this second uh like there's
9 000 buyers for every house that's for
sale and that kind of stuff and so um
you know it's not a bad time to sit on
the sidelines anyway and let's just take
some steps but i might take a different
step than saying i got to go get an mdf
before i'm
qualified knowledge base wise to do
ministry not true
um not true that's not it's not an
accurate one of my dear friends when
stacy and i lived in richmond virginia
when we first got married went to a
church and the pastor there was probably
32 and it was in his first senior pastor
job had worked his way into it and he
got his md while being a pastor yeah
i've got i know several guys so that's
that's a very normal path as well sure
and the church will pay for it yes most
of the time it's not unusual at all i've
been in several situations where the
associate pastor was working you know
continuing i mean it's continual
personal growth in your field of
endeavor and so you got to do something
to continue your personal growth and
um
you know ignorance is not good in any
field
so um yeah that that's not an unusual
growth path for
someone sitting in an associate pastor
role or a young adult's pastor role or
whatever to be working on that and many
times the church if it's a church of
size will pay for it
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
let's
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess with health care costs
rising learn how christian healthcare
ministries can help you make the most
out of your budget visit
chministries.org budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host in the lobby of ramsey solutions
on the debt free stage jonathan and
sarah are with us hey guys how are you
good good doing great good to have you
guys where do you live phoenix all right
and you're all the way to nashville to
do a debt
scream how much have you paid off uh
thirty two thousand
thirty two six eighty one yep all right
very good and how long did that take
13 months okay very good and your range
of income during that time uh about 80
80 000 to 120 i'm a realtor so it kind
of bounces up and down a lot okay cool
and what do you do sarah
i am a signing agent and i also um am
the project manager for our new business
okay very cool like a sign language
agent like signing agent i work for a
title company oh oh oh oh okay
that would be cooler well we've actually
had we when we've done live events we
have people do sign language and there's
usually a local agent that'll book them
for us
and that's what i thought you were
talking about so i just learned
something okay but instead you work for
a title company and he works for a real
estate company now i'm catching on okay
all right very good what kind of debt
was the 33 000
a little bit of everything we had a
couple credit cards student loans
medical debt car payment irs debt yep
hire a lot of irs debt y'all are kind of
normal
yeah just a little bit of everything
yeah just walking along no money
making making money but no money
absolutely pretty much how long you been
married oh 12 years 12 years yeah so
what happened a year and a half ago that
was the wake up call that gets you on
your ramsay journey tell us how you
hooked up with us oh well we've actually
been listening to you for like our whole
marriage we just got serious about two
years ago um
we had to sell our first house because
we couldn't pay our our debts
uh we thought that would fix the problem
uh but it didn't we still started
accumulating more and more debt and it
still wasn't working so we actually got
out of debt about seven seven months ago
um officially and that's about two years
ago we we got really serious uh we had
our second child and now we have three
and we're like yeah this this isn't
working
yeah wow okay so then you just get you
decided you weren't going to just listen
to the radio you're going to actually
freaking do this stuff you know right
absolutely all right well the wake-up
call was there babies will wake you up
yeah yeah in more ways than one yeah oh
yeah yeah they'll get it going yeah it's
fascinating that for nearly your whole
marriage 12 years you were familiar with
ramsey solutions and what dave teaches
and everything and then yeah so you
agreed with it it just wasn't urgent
enough and then all of a sudden whoa we
got to do it so i'm just curious when
you make that decision what actual
changes did you make was it right away
was it a week later how abrupt and
intense was it yeah it was i would say
it was pretty right away um we
got the the ramsey plus app which now is
called the every dollar at the time it
was ramsey plus and um
that i think was a big catalyst like
watching what our money was doing every
month and and we were every week we per
month we'd sit down and look at it
together
she started getting really like awesome
crazy selling stuff craig's listing
things facebook marketing things a way
to like pay off extra little chunks of
debt uh so she was probably the most
inspired then i kind of jumped on board
and sarah did you ever sell anything
that was his and he didn't want you to
sell
no he doesn't really have a lot of
things that would be super valuable
make a lot of money i'm not sure what
that says but that's what might be the
computer and the tv but i use that too
so
we can't get rid of that of course he
doesn't have anything super valuable she
wanted to sell that's what i was right
exactly that's right and we're going now
we got it yeah and it was hard too
because like the nature of his business
is he gets these commission checks and
sometimes they'd be really big
commission checks and we we'd think
about all the things we wanted to spend
our money on we're like oh we could with
ten thousand dollars we could do all our
flooring we could you know paint the
walls we do all this stuff that we
wanted to do and then like we would sit
there and be like okay but if dave
ramsey was here sitting with us and he
hurt our situation
what would he say
and it was always we got to pay off all
the debt so it was just it was awesome
because like sometimes i'd be like i'd
be tempted to be like okay let's use
this commission check to buy something
and he'd be like no we can't other times
he'd be like well let's use this
commission check to to do this and i'd
be like no we can't what would dave
ramsey do
which is code 4 not really that i'm
going to come to your house or something
but it's it's really code for
uh what is best for our future right
yeah versus the short-term feeling
absolutely and adults devise a plan and
follow it children do what feels good so
it's you know i i used to kind of go
that's weird people go what does dave
say it doesn't matter what i say really
what matters is what you do but really
what that's code for if you decode it
it's like what is the smart thing for me
10 years from today that's the question
you're asking yourself in a sense and
you go oh we got to get out of this debt
because when we get rid of this debt
then we've got money and we're open we
can go other places yeah what's one of
the most extreme things you did we heard
about selling stuff is there something
that was just you look back on you go
man this was this was tough to do some
people make fun of you yeah i want to
hear i want to hear a good story
you got it
i think selling our our first home to
pay off all our debt because we couldn't
make our payments was probably the
craziest thing oh yeah we did we just
yeah because i had just had a baby and i
wanted to stay home with our baby and i
was like there's no way that i can do
this with all the money that we owe
in debt every month and i love the every
dollar app too
because when we finally decided to get
serious we paid for that service because
we didn't want to pay for it before
we're like well we can't pay for this we
need to use this money to make a debt
payment yeah that's ten dollars yeah
we'll take ten dollars a month yeah
every little bit helps so you know like
that's how i felt so we didn't ever we
didn't do that the first time we tried
to do dave ramsey i think i convinced
you at one point uh i was i don't know
what we were watching and i was like
it's 115 bucks for the year but
let's let's do it let's watch all the
videos again let's you know we've got
all the accounts connected so you went
through financial peace university yes
and ramsey plus yeah yeah we did it the
second time and this time it stuck for
us so yeah but we i love the how the
software works where it kind of
allocates all the debt together rather
than all your car expenses like you have
your auto debt you have your gas things
like that with the ramsey um solutions
the every dollar i love that it puts all
the debt together because then you're
like oh my goodness this is all the debt
yeah and it's we were paying 1200
dollars yeah we're like we could be
paying for a whole nother house with
this it was the same yeah it was the
same as our mortgage payment so we were
like this this is not okay wow that's
good and visualizing that is what
changed that's good inside i'll let the
every dollar team know they'll be proud
to hear that
they designed that on purpose i happen
to know that but way to go guys
very very well done okay when people ask
what are you telling the key to getting
out of debt is
um not spending more than you make
that's a good one i'll take that
i think budgeting too and we really
liked sitting down together
every month once a month to kind of go
over things because it kind of put us on
the same page and it got us excited for
the next month it got us excited for the
next payment a regular meeting together
and deciding like hey what do we spend
our money on and
yeah absolutely i think when you do that
you can see that light at the end of the
tunnel and it keeps you going yeah
absolutely otherwise it's just an
oncoming train yeah especially when you
pay off your first kind of chunk of debt
it's like wow we could do this like we
could keep this going it's going to
happen and then it does and
yeah yeah powerful well done you guys
well we have a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you the new book is
coming out in january you're going to
get an early release copy because you're
on your way to being that very soon
that's your next step and we also got a
copy of total money makeover for you to
give away right here at christmas time
and pay it forward and give somebody
else their wake-up call say this is the
stuff we did right here so we're proud
of you here at ramsey way to go
excellent excellent excellent job all
right it's jonathan and sarah phoenix
arizona 33 000 paid off in 13 months
making 80 to 120 count it down let's
hear a debt-free scream three
two one
[Music]
[Applause]
a lot of insight there
you have to uh we talked about that in
the first segment we're talking the
young man paying off his car
you have to change some things in your
life permanently that are behaviors
and um
sometimes you're almost doing them
symbolically but other times you're
doing them tactically and practically
but the rhythm of doing the budget
together and looking out in the future
and going okay what would we do if we
were thinking about our future selves
translation what would dave ramsey do
but i mean what would we do if we're
thinking about the future and being wise
this is what we would do yeah
very well done very good stuff jonathan
and sarah are heroes from phoenix
arizona they took control of their lives
i'm proud of them well done well done
this is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you for joining us america ken
coleman ramsey personality best-selling
author is my co-host today
open phones triple eight eight two five
five two two five pedro is with us and
he is in hartford connecticut hi pedro
welcome to the ramsay show hey how are
you dave are you able to hear me
absolutely what's up
oh my god i'm so excited i've been
watching it for the past three years but
i'm just thrilled please speaking to you
i don't know
thank you you're to need to speak
directly into your phone it's a little
bit muffled how can we help
yes so i'm going to um well me and my
family we are going through a crisis at
the moment
and as in regards to
my mother brother
and
what is going on is that he's not
respecting some of the boundaries
that we got in place at home
which is causing difficulties
around the house and i wonder how can we
um
move forward as a family as we try to
deal with that situation
mm-hmm
how old are you how old is he
he's 17 years old
he's a senior in high school and
what my mother tried to do
when you try to speak to him i'm like
hey david this is um
what's going on around the house uh you
becoming late he's still um you know
smoking marijuana used to do all these
things that we don't want you to do
but david still his name is david but he
still um shows us to
do those actions because he says
your dad's not your dad's not in the
picture
no he's not he's uh well we have
different dads his dad live in
dallas texas
okay
and
how old are you
i'm 22 years old and how many other
siblings does david have he has uh well
he has a lot of them in puerto rico but
living with him right now he only has me
and his little brother his little
brother's like 13 years old
yeah and what year is he junior or
senior in high school
i believe he's a senior this year
[Music]
when does he turn 18
uh
march 4th
okay
march 4th all right
and
what is
really what has happened is that my mom
is like hey that at some point we cannot
keep living like this it's hurtful you
know we seeing the things that he's
doing
that's um
that's causing harm to itself but it's
also hurting me and my mom because we
love them but
we um we just don't know what else to do
dave we tried everything we um we call
um
dcf i've been in the picture the police
has been in the picture um why were they
where were the police in the picture
the police was in the picture because he
um
something happened last year i don't
know the exact details uh
i think he was involved with some legal
uh i don't know the exact details but he
i don't know if he stole something i
think
the the police were involved and that
caused bcf to be involved in the picture
okay that's why
ken nor i our family therapist uh dr
john deloney would be ideal to be
sitting here but he's not so
i'll just play uh papa dave grandpa dad
grandpa dave okay
and that's my only expertise in this
which is in other words very limited and
i've never faced something like this
personally so i i can't imagine the
heartbreak and the the pain that you and
your mom are going through that this uh
that this young man's misbehavior is
bringing to you uh the only hope i've
ever had um
influencing someone
has not been by force although i've been
tempted to once they once
by someone i mean an adult and this this
young man's old enough and physically
large enough that he's acting out as an
adult and so the only thing you can do
is talk him into it in other words and
the only way i've been able to do that
is put someone that has credibility
someone that he believes in
in his face
and um you know it might be that there's
a a couple of guys at the local church
that you guys are members of would sit
down with him and you
and the four of you uh go out for coffee
and they just look at him and go look
knucklehead you're stuck on stupid and
you're getting ready to have a really
long life if you keep living like this
because come march you're not going to
be our problem anymore we're putting you
on the street but after that you're
going to have a long life because
knuckleheads always have a long life
and it's always painful and you're being
a freaking knucklehead
and so when are you gonna straighten up
and be a man instead of a little boy and
who's gonna call him out on that where
he's gonna listen and i don't know who
that is
um but he needs the knucklehead speech
because he's stuck on stupid right now
and we gotta unstick him right
absolutely dave and it's yeah and that's
you know we i i
i agree with you i think that somebody
who has who he believes in
can probably help because mom i tried
mom tried hey pedro let me ask you let
me ask you real quick is is mama paying
for anything that he's benefiting from
right now cell phone car what's what's
mama paying for that he's using
um
phone services at the moment
take that away tonight i would take
here's here's the thing i think dave's
right on the knucklehead discussion but
i also think that this is a kid who's
who's hurting
and because he's hurting he's hurting
you all and he's lost he's flailing who
knows what all's going on we're not
privy to that but i would tell you that
he's already causing pain for you and
your mom
and and today's point you're not kicking
him out maybe at this point because he's
not 18 yet but i would take away every
benefit
every benefit that she's paying for i'd
take it away with a very clear
conversation this is why i'm doing this
this isn't working i'm not going to
subsidize fund this anymore it's gone
and you can start to figure it out on
your own plus the knucklehead speech but
i think she's got to cut all benefits
all blessings i've been to connecticut
in march it's cold outside yeah i think
he needs to feel some more pain and
desperation
and i i i
i don't know i mean look dude if you
want to live here these are the
standards and if you're not going to be
up to those standards by march you're
gone now your mom needs to be able to
back that up and say that and you got to
back her up
and between march take stuff away from
him and try to put people in his life to
influence him and help him
um but i don't know how you turn someone
like this sometimes they have to hit the
wall on their own yeah
and until they
until they find some pain they don't
they don't get a wake up call the 12
steppers talk about that all the time
you have to hit bottom
before you you know and sometimes you
hit bottom hard
before you get this stuff but um
you know he's uh
he's mighty cocky for a guy with a warm
pillow
and so um you know we can get him a cold
one that's all i know to do i don't know
how to do it otherwise and that's not
being tough or mean or angry it's tough
love because the current thing we're
doing is creating a juvenile delinquent
and so we have to not keep doing what
we've been doing
so we have to try something new and that
is an act of love because it's not going
to be easy for you and her
to watch someone that you love be on the
street
pedro i ask you a quick question the
consequences that are coming from his
behavior are they hurting you and your
mom more or hurting him more
um
i would say it's hurting him more yeah i
think even though i don't i don't
he's not as open to me yeah maybe an
afternoon maybe an afternoon lunch at
the homeless shelter would be good for
him yeah
that's where you're going to be boy
yeah yeah and then i know that
he um
he doesn't want um he has some mental
health issues they're not act
bad but he doesn't want to that's a
whole different equation you just change
it right we offer her yeah right we
offer her they like dude like we could
help you if you want to see someone and
we're there for you but he denies
everything and what he's trying to give
him yeah if you want to stay here here's
the rules
and you're going to do these things
you're going to be in on time we're not
smoking pot we're not stealing stuff and
you're seeing a counselor that will pay
for if you're not willing to do these
things then we are not going to
participate in your downfall we love you
too much for that
and that's what some people call tough
love i think it's just called love
actually but um and i don't know how to
do that other than that if there's some
way you can love this guy well and some
other way you can put your arm around
him and walk with him that's softer or
gentler than that i would try to find
that
because that that's a very harsh
um
thing we're discussing here but i
ultimately that's where you're headed um
because you know
enabling does not help anyone
just putting up with it in other words
doesn't make anybody get better
never has
you got to do the work to decide and
ouch
[Music]
the hard thing the hard thing dude and
keep in mind none of us are licensed
therapists to give you advice we're just
a couple of old farts sitting here
giving you our best shot at it
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host thank
you for joining us ken coleman ramsey
personality best-selling author of the
book paycheck to purpose is my co-host
today we're taking your questions about
life money career jobs whatever you want
to do it's the ramsey show which means
it's all about you the phone number is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five michael is in orlando hey michael
welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave and ken thank you so much for
talking with me i just need to start off
by saying you need to apologize to kelly
your screener for me because i i had to
lie a little bit to get on the phone
with you but since i got you on the
phone here i just wanted to let you know
dave
i called you a year and a half ago
you recommended us to sell our condo
because the hoa dudes were insane well
we finally did that
we have a hundred thousand dollars in
equity and we are we just paid off their
credit cards last night and we just want
a little direction
how should we
properly invest this money so we don't
squander it on dumb things like tractors
and
stuff we don't
need okay
i'm confused why you had to lie to get
that question on
she because we tried three times and she
said we can't take that now you got to
call back another day so
okay well what happened was you got
lucky kelly wasn't here laura was here
today
so
all right
that's okay so you got a hundred thou
you got a hundred thousand dollars of
money laying around you're afraid you're
gonna fritter it away
yes sir
okay we have we we're thinking 20 000
for our emergency fund okay we have
three small kids we're not super stoked
on college just because the way the
world is turning however we do want to
maybe stock a bunch away
in mutual funds for them we just don't
know exactly what that looks like and
where we should park most of that money
are you going to buy another house
my wife would like to purchase another
property
house or property and we just don't know
kind of if that's a good time to do that
now or not okay well what i would do is
just give each of these dollars a name
like you named 20 000 of it your
emergency fund i'd set that a separate
account
for emergencies only never touch that
account except for emergencies only and
then if you give um
60 000 down payment on future house a
name i'd put that in a different account
also
and then that keeps you from none of
these accounts are attached in any way
to your
checking account
so you can't get to it easily and uh the
both of you agree that we're not
spending this money it's our house down
payment money it's our emergency fund
money we're giving it a name it now has
a purpose it now is a mission it can't
function otherwise outside of its
mission that it has now been given
and if you want to spend uh you know the
remaining money if there's any remaining
money after that that still needs a name
give it a name we're gonna we're gonna
uh enjoy some of this money this amount
of money for enjoyment meaning we don't
have to report back to ourselves on it
we can spend it without regret we're
gonna uh be generous with some of this
money hey it's the holidays great time
to be generous it's always a good time
to be generous never a bad time to be
generous so maybe be generous with some
of it
but give the dollars an assignment
because when they lay in a
quote unquote savings account that's an
account we put money in take money out
of put and take account
put it in take it out put it in take it
out and it doesn't have a name and it
does get
frittered away at that point yeah it's
too much of a temptation and i love what
you're saying there dave putting a name
on it then don't just put a name on it
make the decision go ahead and put it
there like get it out there sit down and
go what's most important i think you got
to look at the big picture too and you
get a big sum of money like this i think
obviously the savings part is huge some
celebration is i think very healthy but
then you gotta say okay what's the best
use of this money
long term let's look at our joint goals
as a couple what matters most this money
needs to go to fund that not just well
you could buy a house what makes a 10
year old 10 year from now version of me
happy with the current version yes i
like the long view if you come into a
big sum of money like this and this is
of course walking through the baby steps
right so it's not outside of our baby
steps plan but i i think in that
situation i want the biggest roi
yeah i'm gonna make sure i'm out of debt
in baby step two yes and i'm gonna make
sure i have an emergency fund three for
sure
and then you know then you decide what
are we gonna do with this uh we're gonna
invest some of it we're gonna put some
up for kids college uh we're gonna uh
put towards the house uh i don't care
what you do with it the trick is this
what you're concerned about is the most
important concern is you want to be
intentional
not accidental adults devise a plan and
follow it children do what feels good as
long as you have a plan no one sits down
and goes i'm gonna intentionally be
stupid
we all wander into stupid because we
didn't have a plan that's right i
actually want to ask you a question
because he brings a very good point and
i you and i are a little bit uh
different on the college play
i'm a guy that goes if it's not the the
only way to get where you want to go or
the best way don't do it
he has to bring us a very interesting
question so i have a question for you on
behalf of the audience because i want to
know what you think so let's he's saying
well we don't know if they're going to
go to college is college going to be
relevant is basically what he was saying
it'll still be relevant on some level uh
but as a parent so they're walking the
baby steps and they're like i don't know
if our kids are going to go to college
whether you agree with them or not on
college as a destination if they pause
or they just don't do that step what do
you advise them to do with that money if
they're not going to invest it for their
kids college well i think you should i
think you should regardless i think you
should save some for college because
education of some kind
is going to apply to a 529. i mean you
can go to technical school and use your
529 that's what you can get a welding
degree that's right and get your 529 and
so if you you know and you're going to
have to learn to do something right so
the 520 potato is not a job you know and
so
it's like you got to have something you
can do and you're going to have the
brain power the skills to do that thing
and generally that's going to require
some training that you pay for would 529
also go towards like technical training
any kind of trade anything yes okay now
anything that falls under quote higher
education that's what i thought yeah and
so and it goes to your spouse and to
your siblings as well you go your mom
and dad can use it
uh kid can use it it doesn't have to be
that kid if they if that kid just
decides to go and if they do go to
school and they do get scholarships
the scholarship you can take out say you
get uh 8 000 scholarship that year you
can take 8 000 out of 529 and pay no
taxes and no penalties on it yup so
completely tax-free growth you can take
out the equivalent amount of the
scholarship each year and file it on
your taxes and you have no taxes on it
follow-up question on that i've always
wanted to ask you this and it's relevant
at this moment
let's say they're walking the baby steps
out and the kids are
late elementary maybe fifth sixth grade
what do you recommend as far as the
amount
if they're playing so they're now they
haven't been able to invest from the
time the kid is maybe a toddler you
probably can't do enough no to overdo it
right so you're saying play catch-up
aggressive late that late in the game
you probably can't
most people won't have ten thousand
dollars a month or something they're not
gonna put that kind of it's not a
situation and there's not a 529 that
will allow that right but um but but you
you probably can't either by law or by
personal income capacity
have room to overdo it if you're getting
started in their 12. you only got six
years exactly so you're not gonna you're
gonna be short right even if you wanted
to pay for it so in most cases so uh uh
you know just look at that and make some
common sense decisions but i think it's
um
it's a bad idea not to save for making
your brain grow
for your three-year-old your
three-year-old needs to have a growing
brain when they're 18. right and we need
to invest in that and so just saying i'm
not going to have my throat i'm not
going to have their brain grow no i'm
not up with that
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free
shipping with blinds.com there's no need
to renovate your entire home just change
out what's on your windows with upscale
choices like faux wood blinds cellular
and roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones if you want to
talk jobs career money life we're here
to help the phone number is triple eight
eight two five
two
brittany is in seattle hi brittany how
are you
hi dave thank you so much for taking my
call sure what's up
um i just want to first say that your
book total make money makeover and the
podcast really changed my life and my
financial future um i'm on baby step
four and in addition to this i have
about fifty thousand dollars saved for a
home purchase although around seattle
good job
it's a really high cost of living area
here so i know it's going to take me a
lot longer to buy and i'm in no hurry to
do that the reason for my call though is
my grandmother passed away
earlier this month and she left me with
a hundred thousand dollar inheritance
and i just want to make sure that i
honor her memory by doing the right
thing with the funds
um
so i laid out a couple of options
first being should i add it to my home
fund second being should i buy index
funds
or third i what i really want to do is
potentially use a small amount to
facilitate a career change but i'm not
really sure where to start so that's
kind of where i'm at with things
okay
the greatest rate of return will be the
career change
yeah that's where you'll make the most
money on the money you invest assuming
you're investing in
uh some kind of certification or
education that's going to allow you to
make more money
yes
so what are you talking about doing
i work in um
for a large tech company out here and i
make great money right now but i don't
love my job what i would eventually like
to do is own my own business
and
potentially work in real estate i'm
really good at numbers i love working
with people too
um but that's like such a big jump that
i'm not really sure where to get started
i know though that that's what i'm
supposed to be doing is helping people
okay so define that a little bit more
what do you make now
uh i think 180. okay here okay go ahead
can i'm sure what define define the real
estate and numbers so is that all one
thing or was that i want to do some real
estate i also love helping people
because i'm good with numbers can you
define that more specifically give me
that at least at this moment that top of
the mountain that you're aiming for
yeah so i okay so i guess it's less
about money but i like to be the person
that kind of fits with people learns
about their needs and then helps them
get to the next step
when i was a lot younger i wanted to be
in finance and i'm good with numbers and
i was good at advising people the reason
i brought real estate up is i just find
that world and that
area to be really fascinating and i'm
passionate about it i like learning
about real estate
i think potentially
um fixing up homes and then reselling
them could be really interesting
so i don't know if that's enough
definition but uh no that's good okay so
i think
yeah well so here's the deal this could
be at both end and i think what you have
to do i'll just motor through this
because it's really simple
you're kind of paralyzed with where do i
enter in because you're not quite sure
what mountain you want to climb it's
either well i'm not i'm not sure so
here's what i want you to do i want you
to spend some time with a ramsey smart
investor
in your area i want you to look them up
you probably already use one i hope
you're using one locally i'd spend some
time with them coffee and lunch and
really just do a quick term paper style
questioning on them like you're doing a
college term paper
and get the ins and outs the highs the
lows because this this this enjoyment
for advising people and this enjoyment
with numbers and helping people take
steps that's a guide that's an advisor
and so i would look into that because
you know being a smart investor pro that
fits really well with what you're saying
but then helping people make decisions
on their home that's a big financial
decision eventually getting into all
cash of course your own real estate
investing that's a part of the process
as well it doesn't have to be either or
it could be both in but it could be
seasons but i think what you have to
determine is would i rather sell homes
and help people get a home or would i
rather advise them on their investing
and their retirement because once you
decide which of those is going to give
you the most juice
that becomes now okay how do i enter
into that so i'm clear get clear stage
one stage two is i have to get qualified
to do that what do i have to learn do
how much is going to cost how long is it
going to take then it's not so scary and
the hundred thousand could go or or some
of that could go towards that financial
training but i think on the career side
depending on what dave wants to weigh in
on the hundred thousand
uh you got to get a little bit more
clear you're really close
then you know
what the pathway is and then we know how
much that's going to cost yeah it sounds
like um i'll give you an example of what
could happen you could say all right i
want to be a real estate agent making
200 000 a year and in order to do that
it's going to take me two years six to
eight months of that is going to be
getting licensed and starting my
training process while i keep my 180 000
a year job
maybe the next six months is even
selling real estate part time while i
keep my 180 000 job uh and then once
i've got some
closings in the hopper uh and and some
notches in my belt so to speak then
maybe the next year i make a jump and
maybe i don't make 180 but i only make
120 so we budget 60 of this to cover the
difference if you even need all of that
to live that's true and so i'm good with
holding all of it back
for the transition
as long as the transition is done with a
plan and not just this i'm going to leap
off the cliff and hope
that i i you know i i really needed an
extra large parachute but i brought an
umbrella that's not a good plan because
you can blow through that hundred grand
in a heartbeat right if you do that so
you need a detailed plan of exactly
how this is going to cause you to make
the transition but if you end up at the
end of this story having used some of
the 100 000 to make the transition into
being a real estate agent that makes two
hundred thousand dollars a year and you
gave up 180 000 our job to do that that
was a good move yeah if you end up being
a real estate agent that makes 30 000 a
year and you gave up 180 000 a year that
was a dumb move yeah not a good move and
same thing by the way the same thing
that dave just walked through that works
on the other side if you want to go into
financial investing and and here's the
key day job to dream job
you've got a great day job you do not
have to jump and just go wee off of a
cliff here we can incrementally get to
this top of this new mountain yeah don't
don't marry poppins it doesn't yeah
please do the umbrella it's not
necessary my goodness a hundred and
eighty channels the only one that flies
with an umbrella the rest of us don't so
it's just right it's mary poppins rules
that's right uh i i tell you what hang
on we're going to send you a copy of
ken's book from paycheck to purpose that
will help you make that analysis and
then once you've made this decision then
that will tell you how much of the money
is freed up
to maybe put into an index fund for a
future home purchase you might do a
one-two combo of those two
ideas jeffrey is in salt lake city hi
jeffrey welcome to the ramsey show
how you doing dave great man what's up
i am 16 years old and i am wondering
what i should be doing with my money as
far as saving it and investing it
okay uh do you have a car
i do it is paid off i paid in cash and
the only thing i pay for is insurance
and gas
how much money have you got saved
um i've got roughly about five grand
saved up that i have not touched in a
couple of months wow you're a stud
well done where are you getting all this
money
uh i work as a server at a local diner
just down the street from where i live
yeah you've been working your butt off
too all right uh good job man well done
uh
are you going to college
uh i haven't quite made that decision
yet uh as of right now i'm looking
towards a trade school um and just get a
degree something in there how you gonna
pay for it
uh ideally with cash and i don't want to
go in debt as as i get older so you
gotta pay for it mom and dad aren't
gonna write checks
no okay i'm paying for it okay well i
can tell you what are you thinking of
studying in trade school
um i'm thinking about following what my
cousin did he went to an audio
engineering and uh did an internship
down in l.a okay so i'm thinking of
following a similar path to that because
he's uh for him being 19 he is making a
pretty penny yeah okay do you have any
interest in audio engineering or does it
just look cool because your cousin's
making good money
i i've been uh so i'm a musician i've
played drums for ten years okay the
audio
it's been very special to me so i want
to try to make that a job that i enjoy
and want to go to got it all right well
jeffrey i wouldn't do anything fancy
with this money
because the best my return on investment
that five thousand dollars will give you
at 16 years old is to invest in some
kind of education
and that's what i would hold that money
for so i would set it aside on a simple
savings account and keep piling it up
see how big a pile you can have and so
you can write a check and go become
educated in whatever it is
feet whatever field it is that you're
going to move into and pay cash for it
that's going to give you the best rate
of return
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying sixty thousand dollars about
two years after that i got a remote job
that pays me a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech you could be next
get started today at betheltech.net
and get one thousand to twenty five
hundred dollars off of your tuition
again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at
825-5225
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage sam and samantha are
with us hey guys how are you hey good
how are you hello how are you doing
where do you guys live orlando florida
awesomeness welcome to nashville thank
you
very cool so how much debt have you guys
paid off
59 000
in six months good for you
and your range of income during that
time uh we signed off at 150 000 to 200
000. cool what do y'all do for a living
uh i am a ct tech travel ct tech
and i'm a medical dosimetrist ah both of
you there huh okay cool
very good how long you all been married
just over one year all right all right
who what's the 59 000 in debt a little
bit of everything we had uh credit cards
um student loan
uh car note and also like a parent
student loan okay so both of you brought
dad in yes okay so what happened right
as you're getting married you looked at
this thing and said okay we have two
messes we're gonna make a big mess in a
one pile when we get married but we're
gonna clean it up fast tell me the story
how did you get connected to us and what
are you doing uh what ended up happening
was the smart conference last year in
november and um
we got a free consultation with a
financial coach
and ever since then is kind of when
everything took off we kind of saw what
we were spending and that was very
eye-opening and then kind of realizing
how much we needed for our future for
retirement that was kind of like wow
like we we need to get serious about
this we need to do something because we
want to we want a big retirement we want
a good comfortable retirement yeah
you're working too hard to be broke yeah
you make a lot of money and you're broke
exactly all right cool so you sat down
with a coach and then what happened
um and then so we've been with um our
coach daniel huck for a year now
and he got us through our budget and he
kind of gave us some tough love which is
what we needed
and we just attacked the debt we it kind
of just it literally snowballed we just
got so excited every debt we would pay
it became more addicting to pay more and
more debt off so we just got so excited
every time we would pay we just it was
great yeah and that's ended up what
happened very cool so the one-on-one
coaching was your whole deal yes it was
it was huge wow once he got us to do the
first budget we did the budget before we
started the program and um
when we realized where our money was
going because we were both
sporadic spenders you know we just used
to just spend whatever we wanted to we
had you know big shovel so we decided to
just you know put it down on paper and
look at it and and realized wow we're
really spending a lot of money on things
we should not be spending money on what
i felt like not a lot to show for it i
guess if that made sense yeah that's
kind of disgusting yes yeah you've got a
healthy level of disgust absolutely yeah
it's funny to watch you laugh samantha's
he was describing that i want you to
talk about that when the coaches get in
there and they start really working with
you on this whether it's one of our
coaches or you know a great
accountability partner or somebody in
the financial peace university class
what happened where you went oh my gosh
because you were laughing thinking about
something yes i was thinking the biggest
for me was the food and grocery budget
and that was huge because when we when
he gave us our like budget that he
wanted us and i was seeing how much we
were actually spending that was like
hugely eye-opening like where we were
versus where we should be and i was kind
of like wow that was crazy and he even
told us a story about his
um what he does because he's really
just very dave ramsey and he would split
his cheese in half because that's just
they don't have extra budget exactly and
so that was like wow like people are
doing this he's serious and we want to
be serious yeah
absolutely wow split the cheese in there
yeah i i don't know i haven't heard that
one i mean like you mean like one square
of cheese
oh my gosh that's next level i've heard
of rice and beans now it's half a slice
of cheese dave it's gone next level and
worse than that it was called very dave
ramsey
by the way people don't know this but
i've seen dave fix his own burger it's a
whole bunch he does a whole piece of
cheese yeah he really does well when
it's in the budget you can have the
whole thing
there it is
well played yeah good answer good answer
oh man well done you guys how's it feel
to be free amazing yeah very good it's a
feeling that i didn't know existed i
didn't realize what it would feel like
until it happened yeah you ever been
debt-free as adults no
neither one of you we went normal yeah
and then you combined and
then now you cleaned it up yep yeah
absolutely what do you tell people the
key to getting out of that is um for us
i guess budgeting dedication and working
together yeah definitely every month we
would sit down and and budget and talk
about what we want to do what we want to
focus on
and uh yeah just being on the same page
now we're using every dollar you're
doing it on paper just on paper yeah
paper okay yeah remembering our why too
yeah was the future and with a little
one on the way now it's even a bigger
why
so that was big for us just to remember
the why yeah change your family tree
yeah correct yeah i saw all that stuff
is singles now we're married now we're
got a baby on the way now we're grown up
now we're gonna live big time yeah yeah
well done y'all yeah very very very well
done so proud of you well we've got a
copy of baby steps millionaire for you
that's a pre-release copy
and that's the one we send out to the
press the advanced reader copy and
that's the next chapter for you guys
now you're on your way to do that and
build some serious wealth and generosity
and be set up for this new baby this is
very very cool and a copy of total money
makeover for you to give away and pay it
forward here through the christmas
holidays and have a chance to say merry
christmas and get somebody started on
the same journey you started on a year
ago yep yeah wow and you did this in six
months i mean you guys leaned in yeah i
even got rid of my mustang
yeah i had it for one year but you know
i enjoyed it while i had it and that was
the decision i made you know it's like
we have we got to go gazelle type so
what did that sell for i actually uh
last year january it was uh 21 000 i
sold it for which is what i owed left on
it so okay so you broke eve yeah on that
i told him 21 000 of the 59
and then game on and six months later
you're done yeah
so a little bit of a tear when it left
the driveway yeah a little bit not gonna
lie a little bit i would have i got a
little cheering it wasn't even mine you
gonna get another one um someday you
know one day it's crazy because you know
i say i when i sold it i said yes
absolutely once i get the cash i'm gonna
buy it but now that we have the cash you
know to buy it
now i don't want to buy it yeah you know
you know maybe buy that ten thousand
fifteen thousand dollar car that's gonna
keep me going so there you go when you
uh when you have to spend like real
money yeah instead of borrowed money
it's it's a different flavor change is
the old priority it's a game changer
there's things around yep so well done
you guys i'm so proud of you thank you
you're so fun who are your biggest
cheerleaders um our coach dan huck and
then my mom yeah
yeah so mom's proud so proud getting
ready to be grandma is this her first
baby yes first grand baby yeah she's
excited
her life is good
great stuff good job you guys very very
well done all right it's sam and
samantha orlando florida 59
000
paid off in six months making a hundred
and fifty to two hundred count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three two
one
[Music]
[Applause]
you know they got through that debt-free
scream about the same pace they got
through that 59 000. yeah that's quick
they don't mess around they did a good
job on it very impressive
great couple so here's the deal when we
tell someone they say we've got all that
debt and i say well you're just normal
that's not a compliment
right no by the way normal sucks in
america
78
of americans have too much month
left at the end of the money yeah that's
eight out of 10 houses on your street
are out of money before the month's over
yeah
there's a lot of stress
the number one cause of divorce in north
america today
credit card debt is a way of life
there are entire segments of the
population that think you can't own a
car or house without a car payment or
house payment
there are entire segments of the
population think you can't be a student
without a student loan right
normal sucks uh they'll forget the
amount of people in the population that
think it's okay to go into debt for
christmas presents oh very normal oh
very normal oh that's horrible i know
it's horrible yeah
be not conformed
to this world
but be transformed
by the renewing of your mind
new ideas
and new behaviors
change
everything
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
well christmas is coming up you hear it
it's coming at you tick tock tick tock
here it comes it's in december this year
they don't move it uh how you gonna pay
for presents the bigger grocery bills
the travel you need a plan
and that's one of the things we do in
financial peace university is we make
sure you have a plan not only for
christmas but for the rest of your life
and you can still get ready for
christmas you can make it
in financial peace university you learn
step by step not only how to get out of
debt
how to save money how to build wealth
but outrageous generosity all with
intentionality
in fact the average household saves
twenty seven hundred dollars and pays
off fifty three hundred dollars in just
the first 90 days
and financial peace university is
available as a part of your ramsey plus
membership
and you don't have to live with a
stressed out christmas year after year
you can make this the year that right
here at the end of 21 going into 22 you
can just step it up and say that's it
we're doing it you can get started today
or you can give fpu as a gift by
visiting ramseysolutions.com
fpu
always ramsey solutions ramsey solutions
dot com slash fpu
financial peace university almost 10
million people have now been through
this class wow it changes
everything for you
kathy is with us in phoenix hi kathy
welcome to the ramsay show
hi thank you for taking my calls sure
what's up
well i'm not calling for myself my
husband and i are debt-free and have
really just always lived you know
by saving money and and and not living
beyond our means i'm calling about my
son um because we constantly have a
battle with him he is 24 years old he's
amazing he is uh
he's worked a full-time job for the last
two years since he graduated
and he also sells tennis shoes on the
side
and
he has saved up about a hundred and
twenty thousand dollars
um
but he does not believe in putting any
of his money into the bank he
he tells us why would i do that if i
make twenty percent by reinvesting it in
tennis shoes and reselling them
so he's now he makes
sixty thousand dollars a year and he's
made in the last year about sixty
thousand dollars profit from selling
tennis shoes so all that money just goes
right back into tennis shoes
and i guess i'm old school
it's hard for me to understand that he's
not putting some of it away
and not just reinvesting it constantly
in tennis shoes
and he just recently bought a car
and he put down ten thousand and he's
financing twenty thousand and it set a
six percent compounding interest
and i'm i'm telling him no you have the
money pay cash and he's like why would i
do that i'm making 20 off these tennis
shoes
and then my last problem that we always
have with him is he wants to quit his
job and open up the tennis shoe store
and he's going to have to pay 75 000
down for that
and he has this debt and so
he he convinces me when i talk to him
that
i'm like well i guess i'm just
that's smart that's smart but i listen
to your show all the time
and i'm almost positive that that it
might not be the smartest thing for him
to be doing
can i ask a quick clarifying question
you let off by saying he saved a hundred
and twenty thousand dollars then you
went into all these details and it got
murky for me does he have a hundred and
twenty thousand dollars in cash sitting
in a safe he said he won't put it in the
bank i'm confused
no he has about twenty thousand dollars
in cash and he has about a hundred
thousand dollars in ten issues
oh and inventory
in inventory so he goes to different
tennis shoe shows and he sells to also
different uh tennessee stores and he
will sell them make twenty percent
and then he will reinvest all that money
uh he lived with us for two years but he
is now on his own okay
all right
so um
number one uh
forget all the tennis shoes and the
money for a second um
the hardest stage of parenting for me
has been when i no longer had control
over my kids because they grew up
i agree a lot a lot of
your sentence structure and the way you
told the story told me that you're
struggling with some of that too
a hundred percent and
i am trying really hard to let him do
his own thing yeah
but it is hard but i also want to get it
it's hard to watch people you love do
something that you think is stupid
right or questionable in judgment or
whatever phrase you want to put on it so
number one thing is um
just uh
papa dave to uh mama kathy
um
you're gonna have to start treating him
like he is the son of one of your
friends
who's 24 and he's like a man and stuff
yes because you're using your mom voice
on him i heard it
and it has no power anymore
i know
if you were talking to the son of your
friend you would use the persuasive
voice and i never heard you use it yet
okay so that's thing one regardless of
what the content of our conversation
from this point forward is that's your
only shot
because this boy is known as a man now
he lives on his own he pays his own
bills he he's he's free he's allowed to
do whatever he wants and he's no he's
not living his life to please his mom
anymore
and it's not his job to either you
wouldn't want him to
that would be known as a mama's book i
know that'd be a mama's boy
you didn't raise him to be that you
raised him to be a man all right now
then let's go to if i was coaching my
son's friend who was 24 not my own son
how would i talk to him about this okay
you have done an amazing job young man
with this tennis shoe thing you are a
freaking entrepreneurial rock star i'm
so proud of how much money you've made
now what you need to do to go to the
next level if you were to ask me you
might not be asking me but if you were
to ask me as a person who's older and
know something about business i would
say that you have too much tied up in
inventory
if he were coming to one of our entree
leadership courses and i was sitting and
having a cup of coffee with him at the
break
at the edge of the stage i would tell
him you have too much tied up in
inventory you're illiquid and uh you
need to slow down just a little bit
you're making really good money and you
fooled yourself into thinking you're a
genius you need to slow down about two
three clicks
and no you don't need to open a store
right now you're making bank yeah you
may want to quit your job and do tennis
shoes full time because you're
apparently very good at it you pay off
this stupid car that was ridiculous and
um then you need to just work your
tennis shoe business and do it out of
the out of the you know how the
apartment or whatever you're doing it
out of now don't go open a brick and
mortar to and lose a bunch of money to
because you've got this thing on the run
it sounds to me like he's got an
entrepreneurial gift but he needs some
business acumen to go with it so to
fine-tune some of his finances so that
he can take this tennis shoe thing to
the next level i hope he does that and
walks away from this job and hope he
pays off his car and i hope he doesn't
open a brick and mortar until he has to
later on because right now he's making
bank and he has no overhead ken yeah
kathy i hope you heard what dave said
here there's a lot of practical stuff
but what dave's genius is on this is
that you are now not telling him what to
do but you are now giving him advice on
what he is already doing what he wants
to do it's a total shift and i got to
tell you you said twice in this
conversation and i'm a dad and so i'm
only speaking from where i've blown it
in this particular area i kept hearing
you say i'm trying so hard i'm trying so
hard i think
that's not just a phrase i think that's
your real emotion coming out i want to
tell you to stop trying and dave just
gave you the new pathway you know what i
do i'd send him a link to an article or
two of some hot young entrepreneur who
cash flowed his way to an unbelievable
business give some evidence of what
dave's talking about how cash is king
and how cash eliminates the risk it sets
him up to blow this business up how
brick and mortar is maybe a thing of the
past
things like that that are more like this
is awesome you're doing great i think
what dave just laid out was a pathway
for you to no longer try hard
stop trying
stop stop trying some information some
people in his life to polish this
business acumen yeah and cheer him on
when you give him that yeah because he's
this guy's a stud man yeah he is take he
took air yeah turned it into tennis
shoes yeah he's just young he just
business you know what i do i buy him a
ticket to andre leadership event i'm not
kidding you here i'll tell you let me
send you an entree let's do that let's
give him an entree leadership you know
get him get him to something he's
definitely an entrepreneur he's
definitely got skill and he's got
backbone he's got moxie yeah swagger
yeah i mean this kid man he's he's
amazing yeah he's very impressive so
yeah hang on we'll send you a copy of
entre leadership we'll be cheering him
and you on yeah from the sidelines and
all of us parents who have kids that
grew up
it's a it's a heartbreaking equation
i know it's heartbreaking while they're
still growing dave
oh man and just mixing a little family
business with it so that doesn't make it
that doesn't make this too interesting
oh
you gotta love it this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show did you know the ramsay show
is one of the most popular podcasts in
the world
subscribe or follow today wherever you
listen to podcast
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host you
jump in we'll talk about your life and
your money ken coleman ramsey
personality is my co-host today he's the
host of the ken coleman show heard on
over 75 radio stations siriusxm and a
very popular podcast all across america
answering your questions about jobs and
career and finding that paycheck with a
purpose
so thanks for joining us the phone
number triple eight eight two five five
two two five john is in charlotte north
carolina hey john welcome to the ramsey
show
hey dave uh nice to talk with you a
long time fan a first-time caller uh
actually attended your financial peace
university at our methodist church a
number of years ago and uh really really
enjoyed it uh glad to say that my wife
and i are now debt free good for you and
have been for for some time now so uh
you've really helped us out in in our
finances over the years
but uh i i didn't want to to call in
because i i've got perhaps a common
problem with college age kids and
i think you've touched on this
in the past but
we have three daughters our middle
daughter is a freshman
at a university two hours away
a great kid
she was senior class president athlete
of the year in high school
she's got final exams coming up on our
first
semester
and all indications our grades are going
to be good uh but she's got our finals
here in the next few weeks here
but she's had a
long time boyfriend that's back in our
hometown
he is two hours away from her
and
we are concerned about him
particularly the influence that he is
having over her
this is a kid the boyfriend that has not
graduated college
or high school he stopped
going to school
and uh doesn't live at home with his
parents anymore he's sort of out on his
own
and um there's been talk of our daughter
coming back home
and
not going to college two hours away
because of the normal hey i'm in love
with the with the boyfriend and
over the years the last couple of years
there's been some negative influences
by him
alcohol a little bit him not her
him having his license revoked for a
little bit
those kinds of things
and uh
i have a lot of older
buddies i'll say
that
10 years older than me and
trusted friends that i've bounced this
off of and i'm getting a lot of
different opinions on how to handle this
and i think in the past you have
mentioned hey there's a couple levers
you can pull here persuasion
or the economics or financial aspect of
it
by the way my wife and i are paying for
everything for the daughter car vehicles
food
tuition everything and we plan to do
that for four years
but the boyfriend is just a bad
influence and um if we clamp down on our
daughter
we are
almost certain
uh that she's gonna pick the boyfriend
over
over us and supporting us through
college and um
just not sure how to handle it
what gives you that
that belief you guys there's something
in her
life and her personality that makes you
feel that or is it just straight up fear
any evidence that she would do that uh
she is strong-willed
where her mental state is now is that
she wants to graduate as fast as
possible so she can earn a lot of money
because she knows that he is not going
to earn a lot of money because he does
not have a high school diploma
and so she's obviously in love
and
she's doing everything right except for
the boyfriend
where
uh there's a problem now
here's one thought that is going through
our minds um
in a in a and this is a little crazy
idea but maybe not
um is supporting the boyfriend in other
words being able to prove himself
okay hey come on over to the house for
dinner
and let's have a conversation
and
we would like to support you in getting
your ged
um
and seeing if he takes us up on the
offer
and if he doesn't
perhaps that proves something to our
daughter and she could see
hey he's not going to
really do what he's supposed to
or
a positive benefit to it is hey we've
supported him even though his family
hasn't supported him as much through the
years
and we're helping him our daughter sees
that hey he gets a ged
um and perhaps he's got the ability to
get
a decent job
she your youngest
middle one
okay
what's her uh sisters say about all this
uh the sisters the saint the oldest
sister is a senior in college
um
she's about
whether
to
graduate
she doesn't like the boyfriend okay
that's what i was asking yeah it's
simple yeah yeah yeah and then the
younger turn her loose on her sister
yeah
yeah um
i can tell you my three my three have um
policed each other over at that age
group when they were in that age group
uh they don't now because they have
separate households now and they're all
standalone
adults and they you know they rep they
uh respect each other's boundaries now
but if one of my both my daughters were
in college at the same time if this had
been going on uh
one of the other ones would have
said uh hey you gotta be kidding me this
guy's a loser and she would have called
it out that way you're being real nice
but that's what you're saying
so i think the other only other thing i
can tell you is you probably
you
more than your wife probably have more
influence with her than you think you do
um and i get that from dr meg meeker and
i would pick up the book matter of fact
i'll send you a copy of it called hero
and it's all about how dads are a hero
and that good dads are a hero in their
daughter's eyes
and um you probably can
you're very even-tempered you're not
saying anything flamboyant you're not
going over the top one way or the other
here
you're not abandoning this you're
willing to stand in the gap for her
you're willing to make it difficult for
her for her own good uh but you're
trying to just be wise about how to get
at this whole thing and that tells me
you're probably going to find the right
equation
because of who you are and i think she
knows who you are
and i think the guy i'm talking to is a
guy she'll listen to
and it might be you just uh you make a
couple trips over there for saturday
morning breakfast you make the two-hour
drive
and just start uh speaking into this
situation very bluntly yeah and say you
know
um i've known guys like this my whole
life and um we love you and we're gonna
walk with you we're not gonna abandon
you
but this is a bad situation and i'm
worried about you because i love you i
think she'll hear you more than you
think she will yeah that real quick john
i want you to try smothering this kid
with kindness
asking him what is he planning to do put
some kind pressure on him see if it
freaks him out gets him to leave he'll
run him off
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800 dollars a year go
to puretalk.com and choose the
affordable plan that's right for you
with their 30-day risk-free guarantee
you have nothing to lose go to
puretalk.com and enter the promo code
ramsey to save 50 off your first month
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right listen up everybody i got a
secret to share with you you ready
christmas is 27 days away
27 days hold on a second i got to write
that down that's it it's breakthrough
information right there coleman you
didn't have it
uh they put it on the calendar every
year and yet it sneaks up on us every
year uh we know you're planning to do a
lot of giving and that's why our team
has put everything on sale we're having
our biggest cyber monday sale ever right
now we even added to it because we had a
down time on friday with the website
yeah they gave us the opportunity to
beef up today a little bit
so today only we have special deals from
all of our ramsey personalities the
perfect day to get christie wright's
2022 goal planner rachel cruz's money
assessment ken coleman's career
assessment
lowest prices ever to date
on all of those
get your gifts for your family your
friends even yourself
up to 79 off
our biggest cyber monday sale ever at
our online store at ramseysolutions.com
our question today comes from blinds.com
find out for yourself why blinds.com is
the number one online retailer of custom
window coverings because they're the
best you get free samples free shipping
and with the new promos they run every
month you'll save even more it's a great
american company be sure and check them
out if you need window blinds use the
promo code ramsay to get the best deal
today's question comes from dawn in
california what advice do you have for
stay-at-home moms who want to re-enter
the workforce i have only had one job
and it was many years ago when my
firstborn was little i feel completely
unqualified to go back to work but would
like to get a job so that we can pay off
our debt more quickly should i go back
to school for training or
just jump into something entry-level
well it is a lot of advice that i try to
give to stay-at-home moms and the first
piece of advice is to always look
towards the talent you have you haven't
lost your talent
could you you know go for some new
training and polish those skills
absolutely but in this situation i want
to focus on the debt first and here's
why when you all want to get out of debt
and that's the primary motivation behind
this question that tells me we got some
gazelle intensity and it also tells me
that you're going to be a little bit
more clear a little bit more confident
on finding out what you'd like to do or
not even go back to work once that has
paid off so i think the debt is the
number one priority here i would go get
a job a good paying job because there's
a lot of them right now that allow you
to just simply do something that you're
good at this is talent only here because
our primary motivation is more money
bigger shovel to pay off the debt now as
you get back into the workforce
you're paying off the debt you get some
motivation there before you know it
you're gonna be in baby step three i'd
keep working there and i'd get that that
baby step three fully funded there and
then i begin to think about all right
what is it that i would really like to
do what's the work that i would love
that would create a result that matters
to me that's if you decide to stay in
the workforce so in this situation dave
i'm always going to tell somebody let's
not spend extra money on training right
now let's go get a bigger shovel knock
the debt out then that gives us more
options
completely agree it's all just go make
some money go make and the other thing
is is a body in motion is easier to
redirect than it is to get one in motion
that's right so while you're out there
moving around you may bump into the
thing that lights up your life that's
exactly right and you go well however
that's so fun i like doing that yeah and
or i hate you know this thing i hate
numbers and details yeah okay well that
you know you're going to learn some
things that's going to direct you one
way or the other uh through whatever
you're doing so there's no lost motion
in this as long as you don't feel like
you're stuck in whatever it is it's very
interesting that you use that lost
motion i think that's really deep the
inertia that we see when we listen to
debt-free screamers or we watch them
however you engage with this show and
you watch the stories and you see how
their dreams evolve you see new things
come to life discipline grows that's
what's going on here and it's going to
set you up if as a stay-at-home mom you
want to stay
in the workforce i think the inertia
that the debt free journey provides is
invaluable beyond living like no one
else you know now he can work like no
one else give like no one else i mean
there really is tremendous motivation
that comes from accomplishing something
like that because then you go if i did
that what else do i want to do
but it's funny how many times in our
life that
we were in the process of movement
towards something and that's when we
intersect yes something that's life
changing love whether it's whether it's
actually a career thing it could be you
meet your spouse or she's already
married it could be right you uh you
meet a mentor it could be that you uh i
don't know you you stumble across things
if you're stumbling
forward yeah moving forward just keep
moving just keep moving just keep moving
and so there's some value in doing that
you know you might you may want to make
it a little bit more refined than all of
that though and just go ahead and take
the coleman career assessment well i'd
love for her to do that would help her i
would get you know and give you at least
a a general idea of where i might find
some joy instead of just going well it's
exactly right and and i think you know
i'm answering the question with singular
focus but i think it's a very good point
because here's the deal while i'm
getting out of debt in the just a j-o-b
while i'm getting out of debt i'm doing
the work of discovery i'm taking the get
clear career assessment i'm getting from
paycheck to purpose to see what does it
take to actually reach a professional
pinnacle is it possible it's why we
write books like baby steps millionaires
and from paycheck to purpose so that we
can show you a clear path hey this is
actually possible so there's no question
that while i'm getting out of debt i can
begin to see some things that maybe i
never saw before
and that's what's so exciting sherry is
with us sherry's in dallas texas hi
sherry welcome to the ramsay show
hi mr anthony thank you for taking my
call sure what's up um
well i need some advice um
so i make about
42k a year
um i've been off work a couple of months
i just started back working i was out
because i
gave birth i had a son but unfortunately
he passed away so i was off for a
postpartum and i wasn't receiving any
paycheck your husband passed away after
you had a baby
no my my baby passed away oh my gosh
honey i'm so sorry yeah
thank you so um i was off work i just
started back working for the same
company but i wasn't getting paid
because i didn't have any um any more
sick time available
um i i had about 10k saved up but
right now i'm at about 5k um with all of
my bills so
my student loans i have about 75 000
i have
a couple of credit cards so i've
maxed out one of them which is about 25k
um i have a
truck payment which i pay about 6 28 a
month as well as what do you owe on the
front
i owe about 26 000
and i have like
my rent um is 1700 a month okay and i'm
trying to get out of bed are you married
anyway
no no um we're not married and we just
recently separated
so all the income now is just coming
from me okay and so
i'm just trying to um figure out a way
that i can come out of debt
and and pay these bills down with my
student loans i'm on an income driven
and so i've been at paying zero for that
but i still have you know my what do you
uh what do you do for a living
i do medical billing for a pediatric
company
okay
all right cool
all right um how old are you
i'm 38. okay
and this uh this child that that went to
heaven was your only child
no i have a son who just graduated and
recently went to the navy
and i have a daughter she's 16.
okay
all right
um
okay your math
the math that you gave me is very
stressful
yeah and you're pretty scared
yeah
and you've just been through hell
this year
yeah
yeah
okay
um so um
what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna bust into
this really hard
to help you clean it up as fast as you
can
so i'm going to be real blunt you ready
yes i am all right your truck's insanity
it has to be sold
you can't even come close to keeping a
26 000 truck number two you're gonna
take six extra jobs you're gonna work
all the time
number three you're gonna cut up all
your credit cards and attack them with a
vengeance
number four we're gonna walk with you
and help you with the financial coach
and with ramsey plus going through
financial peace university and we're the
world's best budgeting app and i'm going
to pay for all of it and give it to you
because i've been scared like you're
scared right now and i know how it feels
so you hold on laurel pickup we'll walk
with you kiddo
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage
christopher and amanda are with us hey
guys how are you hi great good good to
have you guys where do you all live
winston-salem north carolina cool
welcome it's good to have you and all
the way over to nashville to do a
debt-free scream that's right very cool
how much have you paid off fifty five
thousand four hundred and forty four
dollars all right very cool and how long
did it take
one year ten months and 26 days one year
ten months and 26 days so 11 months all
right good and your range of income
during that time started at uh 92 000
combined and ending at 107.
ended at 107. what do y'all do for a
living i'm a pastor
and i'm an executive assistant okay cool
very cool so tell me about the 55 000
what kind of debt was this uh mostly
credit cards some car loans um some
personal family loans um
yeah
just the kind of normal yeah kind of
normal all right cool so what happened
uh two years ago approximately where you
guys run into this ramsay stuff how did
this all happen well i i took ramsay uh
fbu gosh 14 years ago
oh
so i knew better but he jokes that i'm a
lifelong learner which really just means
it's slow
wow all right whoa
um so i knew what to do but that didn't
always mean i did what i should do so
yeah i just racked up some some credit
card debt and things just trying to to
make both of our dreams and what we
wanted to do happen rather than
you know planning and budgeting and
doing what we needed to there so so what
was the wake up call two years ago she
was a wake-up call to me i had no clue
that we were in any serious debt i
thought maybe ten thousand or something
so i was shocked when she said it's over
fifty thousand we gotta do something
about this
yeah um well all of a sudden like one
thing had been a credit card had changed
the number and then it went to
collections and then everybody
um
started calling and sending a letter
saying you're your limit is dropping
you're above your limit now your
interest rate is increasing and it was
like
you know
yeah on like seven different cards and
it's like oh
okay we gotta get out of this and um you
know i just got angry when i saw that
one of them was like 25 percent interest
and i was paying you know hundreds of
dollars every month you know they've
been smart if they'd left her alone and
kept charging her interest
when they made her angry she got out of
debt
yeah so christopher she comes in and
goes it's not ten thousand it's fifty
thousand what'd you do
i said tell us what we need to do i'll
go along with whatever we have to do
she had all the plans laid out oh you
already had it figured out she hadn't
figured out when she presented it to me
and i said absolutely let's let's get it
done okay never present a problem
without a potential solution right
wow i like this lady very impressive i
like this lady so what'd you do all
right so i know you laid the plan out
how intense what were some of the big
major adjustments if any that you made
um well i mean just even looking at
everything that we had we mapped it out
for three years it would take us to pay
off everything
and um we just i got to the point where
once we got that first ball rolling and
then the car alone was gone and then it
was like we just have to find money in
the wood works to to pull and pay
towards this and then with the pandemic
with the stimulus money all of that went
towards debt and god was very gracious
to us in the pandemic it turned out to
be a real gift for us
yeah my job continued i got a promotion
during this time and
we just
took every spare penny that came in and
threw it at it and you know came out
a little over a year ahead of our
schedule so yeah you just got after it
knocked it down how does it feel to be
free
grateful i'm just so grateful wonderful
yeah
very cool
very cool now that you did it all and
you brought the plan
what did you do tell folks what the key
to getting out of debt is
um to communicate with each other and to
be diligent like you just have to keep
doing it there were so many times that i
started and stopped and started and
stopped but you know once we finally got
that momentum going don't don't let it
go right
um yeah
okay lean in and knock it all the way
through yeah excellent well done
so uh christopher how long have you been
pastoring
about 30 years okay all right so these
were some scriptures you hadn't brought
up before huh
try not to talk about it too much
do as i say not as i do
but now you're free it opens up a whole
nother section of scripture absolutely
yeah very cool very cool so we have to
ask do you uh do you personally know
santa claus i do not i've never met him
you never met him okay i thought maybe
you had
okay trying to replace him someday okay
do you do this do you do this on the
side no i don't this is just a coveted
beard that started with the pandemic i
thought well i'll get rid of it when the
pandemic ends and it won't go away and
this just keeps getting longer it's
perfect it's a perfect for the season
thank you you got i mean your
conversation piece for sure for sure
i got to tell you i've never seen a
beard move with a person like that does
i don't know what you're doing to it but
that is
i mean you put a lot of time into that
don't you it does take a lot of time yes
yeah all right yeah you got it you have
to at least keep it until january
absolutely you gotta at least do that uh
oh my gosh this is wonderful
[Laughter]
well done well we're very proud of you
guys congratulations very very well done
i love it well we've got a copy of baby
steps millionaires for you that's your
next chapter to become uh outrageously
wealthy and outrageously generous uh
along the way those are two things that
go together and uh very very well done
and that's a pre uh advanced copy of
baby steps millionaire the book actually
comes out no in november and this is
november is over in uh january the 11th
i'll get it out in a minute anyway we've
also got a copy of total money makeover
for you to give away to somebody and
minister to them and
give them a chance to learn this stuff
and actually start doing it so very very
well done good stuff you guys
other questions no i mean you know i i
wanted to ask i did want to know because
the way you answered you're like okay
here's what we did i came in and we just
started pulling money from the woodwork
i want to know
was there a tough tough tough like
sacrifice something where you didn't
want to do it wanted you he's looking at
you with the hand up what is that what's
going on there you
nothing well i mean we just started
like going through and cutting out the
the stuff that we didn't have to pay for
um which is almost everything right
right
like keeping food um internet and you
know that wasn't non-negotiable but
cable is not negotiable for him so
trying to figure out ways around that um
and then
you know we
fairness it was much easier than i ever
imagined it it never felt really bad to
be honest yeah okay a matter of getting
you once you get intentional it moves
the needle right yeah it's just this
living by accident thing you do when you
get on a budget you feel like you got a
raise where'd it all go yeah you know
where'd it all go so well done all right
christopher and amanda winston salem
north carolina count it down 55 000 paid
off in one year and 11 months making
92-107 count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream three two one
we're debt-free you praise god
that is how it's done
well done you guys very very cool
so uh today's uh three hours of debt
free screams are interesting thirty
three thousand fifty nine thousand fifty
five thousand not huge huge amounts but
all done in 13 months six months and one
year and 11 months yes so all done in
under two years uh all done in very
short periods of time very quickly
um all making
looking down the incomes roughly around
100
uh range right around 100 000 range
so nobody making five hundred thousand
dollars a year um and nobody making
thirty thousand dollars a year
uh but uh
in every case incomes went up during the
time that they're working on it which
usually happens
concentrating
and in every case um you know there was
credit card debt uh there was student
loans there was car payments there was
just the normal debt that's out there
the bottom line of the story of the debt
free screams on today's three hours of
shows
has uh it has been that you can do it
yeah you know these people are you
that's right and if we walked out on the
street today with a camera and a
microphone and said do you think you
could pay off 55 000 11 months a lot of
people would look at us like we're
aliens the fact of the matter is you can
but that's a staggering number to most
people on the street they don't think
they think 55 000 in 11 months well it's
actually extremely doable yeah yeah you
just it's beans and rice yes rice and
beans
and it can be done that's right that's
the trick it can be done and that sets
you up then to become wealthy and
outrageously generous
this is the ramsey chef
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today philippians 4 19
my god will meet all your needs
according to his glorious riches
in christ jesus
les brown said too many of us are not
living our dreams because we're living
our fears
ooh less
he's the man yeah you gotta love it all
right up next is mitchell in chattanooga
hi mitchell welcome to the ramsey show
hey guys thanks for taking my call sure
what's up quick quick question for dave
so i've been listening to you for a
while and i know that you're against the
uh traditional va home loan um but i'm a
disabled veteran so i would i would i
wanted your opinion on if you know
anything about the
disabled uh va home loan yeah they waive
a bunch of the fees they wave a bunch of
the fees and the interest rate is better
if you have full disability so that
makes the va loan much much better uh in
your situation okay
yeah and would one of your elps know
more on it well chart show mortgage can
walk you through it that's you know
they're the people we've endorsed for 25
years on mortgages and they can walk you
through what the differences are but
what you'll want to do is just compare a
fannie mae a conventional loan the costs
of closing and the cost of interest
rates and total fees upfront and total
fee and total interest rate and compare
that with a va total up front and you
may find the va give with with a
disability may have a slight edge it may
be better
but that does not give you an excuse to
buy a house with nothing down
no i that's not the plan at all yeah
it's just a matter of interest rate and
fees is all we're talking about and
still on a 15-year fixed and still where
the payment's no more than a fourth of
your take-home pay
but um yes but it's the the uh the
discounts over the standard va loan are
pretty substantial uh with the if you're
you know if you're if you're a disabled
vet so it's something definitely look at
in your case
awesome thank you thank you man
appreciate the call brandon's with us in
rapid city south dakota hi brandon how
are you
good how you doing dave better than i
deserve what's up
so i had a question about a parent plus
loan um so on the parent plus loan as a
primary the parent is
and then the student would be the
cosigner
if the parent were to pass away does the
loan go away
wow
i do not know the answer to that
question it would be logical that it
does because on a
traditional student loan not a parent
loan
uh if the student passes away the loan
goes away and it does not hold the
cosigner liable
so if you went got a student loan and
your grandmother co-signed and you died
in a car wreck the loan goes away or you
become disabled and qualify for ssi the
loan goes away you're beca you're
declared fully permanently disabled uh
on a traditional student loan on a
parent plus loan i don't know the answer
to the question it would be logical that
it does based on the other program the
way the other program works but i would
have to get into
uh you know do a little bit of research
to be able to answer the question well
but that's a really good question have
you looked at it have you looked it up
yeah so uh my girlfriend she has she's
the one that has this uh loan
and
her dad was the the primary on it and he
has stage four cancer
so she's waiting to see he's in chemo
right now so she's waiting to see the
prognosis after this of kind of what's
going to happen and what she should do
if she should pay it off a little
yeah well i mean has she looked it up
and they do forgive it is that has she
found that yet found the regulation yes
so yes the
student loan that she's under she that's
what they had told her
but we were under the grants that we
should just pay it off
um or her and i both agreed is what i'm
trying to say uh because she has the
money to do so uh but felt like she was
you know she might have been being lied
to
well what i do is i want to get the
regulation in writing just send me the
website send me to the the regulation in
the subsection so i can print it off and
date it
um
not just some goob on the phone i don't
trust a goob on the phone with sally may
they they make up crap for a living but
uh i mean navient is known for
that's greek for lying and so um but the
uh uh but yeah you get in there i would
get in there and find something in the
regulations you probably can download
the actual regs off a dot gov site
um i've just never looked it up i never
wondered about it now you got me
wondering about it i'm gonna look it up
but um okay that's how i learn stuff on
the show every week
some question i have to go i don't know
but the uh uh yeah if i were in your
shoes i would dig into the dot gov
stuff on the student loans it's pretty
extensive site
and uh find it or if you get somebody on
the phone that's telling you it is
forgiven great give me a reference point
in the regulations so i can print them
off
a verbal confirmation of that with sally
may's not enough
but once i've gotten that if i get that
confirmation in writing i've got an
actual copy of the regulation
um
you're trying to look it up yeah i mean
but i wasn't going to dive into it
without reading it unless it's very
obvious yeah but the uh yeah
but what i would do is if
i would wait on the prognosis as cold as
that sounds uh to pay it off if you've
got
the confirmation that the loan is
forgiven upon his passing
um
but um
there are a couple articles here uh so i
would do some research but the google
meister yeah it does say that federal
student loans are discharged upon the
borrower's passing that's a standard
federal student loan though i don't know
if that's true on parent plus that's
what i'm wondering yeah but i yeah i'm
gonna get my hands on again something
more than an article too i want to
actually see
the reg and i want to have it in my hand
so it because it's going to come up
later and you're going to have to
present death certificates and other
stuff to get it forgiven uh it's a
process and getting the whole process
forgiven if there's a permanent
disability is a lengthy
process but it can be it certainly can
be done and it's what i would do if i
were in those shoes
so hey good question did you find it uh
yeah
studentaid.gov that's the government
site and i would do the homework there
but it does say in fact that with doc
acceptable documentation the federal
student loan parent plus will be
discharged if the parent dies but okay
do your homework on that yes that's
fresh from google
yeah
yeah everything on the internet's true
so
yeah and ken coleman's an expert at
looking up stuff on google so never done
that before i just thought well i'm
going to hey you pulled it off man it's
a tag team right here there it is so
that's the federal student aid website
apparently that the information you were
given is right but i would get that
website then yeah federal studentaid.gov
and i download not just the q and a i
want to see the reg yep i want to pull
the reg and the uh
you know section
five 11.465 yes or whatever the question
is that's right i want that in my file
uh because i don't trust these people
all right
another brandon is with us this time in
baton rouge hi brandon how are you
hey dave how's it going great man i'm
real short on time ask your question
quick
okay should i could my uh lead my small
business as a contractor 25 000 this
year second year in business
uh take a job 75 000 a year
um traveling superintendent
what kind of contract work
commercial go say so uh construction
construction yes sir yeah i think i
would lean towards the 75 now but could
you keep the small business open on the
side
i can keep my license probably wouldn't
have time to do both but i could
definitely keep the license yeah uh how
bad a financial shape are you in
well i'm 32 with no debt um probably 10
000 in emergency fund
i'd like to save for a house let me ask
you this brandon real quick because we
got about a minute so i'm gonna ask real
fast okay if you had made 75 last year
for yourself would you be calling us
not at all
so here's where i'm going with that
question what's it take to make sense
what's it take to make 75 or make 50.
can you work a side hustle to get a
little bit more money in i know you want
to save for a house but the fact that
you're in decent financial shape well
can you what does it take to get your
business to go from 25 to 75
i just keep keep grinding doing things
i've been doing i think it'll get there
yeah you're brand new no i think you got
to have a big you got to keep grinding
3x you you gotta do something to go
three x here we gotta shock the monkey
yeah
okay you gotta do something big you need
a big plan or you need to take the job
yep and if you take the job brandon you
can lick your wounds on this and go hey
i wasn't a failure i just gotta learn
now and i pay somebody else excuse me
somebody pays me to learn the business
and i can adjust and come back another
day and start your business back this is
not a this is not a be-all end-all here
so jump into entre leadership on the
website i'm gonna send you a copy of the
book before you make the decision if you
can and talk to some other contractors
there yeah because you're probably
really good at your trade but you're not
yet good at marketing and running your
business and if you can get that solved
and stay in business and that's what
you'd rather do let's solve it but just
keep doing more what you're doing and
you only made 25 no you got to have
something you have a big plan here
because you got to get it to 75 it's not
it's not you need to go up 5 000 you
need to go up 50 000
that puts us out of the ramsey show in
the books we'll be back with you before
you know it in the meantime remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the prince of peace christ jesus
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
you